et puis il y à un mot qu'il faut bien
prononcer dans cette émission
claude lévi-strauss parce que votre nom
y est attaché c'est le mot
structuralisme alors structuralisme ceux
qui ne savent pas ce que c'est c'est
quoi c'est une un mode de pensée une
bonne méthode d'analysé une idéologie
qu'est ce que c'est un mot qui a été
tellement mis à toutes les sauces
c'est vrai que moi même je n'ose plus je
n'ose plus l'utiliser parce qu'en
réalité on s'y met c'est magique c'est
une grande nouveauté
pas du tout enfin c'est tout simplement
un effort pour introduire dans les
sciences ou ce qu'on appelle à tort les
sciences de l'homme ou les sciences
sociales parce que nous ne sommes pas
des sciences un petit peu plus de
rigueur que il y en avait précédemment
et en fait c'est qu'on croit qu' il
s'agit d'une découverte récente non le
couac la façon la plus simple de faire
comprendre aux objets sculptures
l'isthme dire nous avons à faire nous
autres qui ont étudié étudiants les
hommes mais sociétés humaines
un des objets qui sont
extraordinairement compliquée qui sont
en réalité beaucoup plus compliqué que
les plus compliquées de ce que nos
collègues biologistes ou physicien
études et donc à la limite nous ne
sommes pas capables de décrire de façon
satisfaisante
un petit peu comme un visage humain
enfin vous pouvez lire pendant vingt
pages de proust la description du visage
de dette de crécy disons vous ne verrez
pas d'être de crécy que vous saurez ce
qu'elle n'avait aucun rapport avec un
rooney la mitis mais je ne saurais pas
vous ne savez pas vraiment vous ne
pourrez pas voir le visage il s'était à
l'époque de la renaissance d'un grand
peintre allemand albert durèrent s'est
aperçus parce qu'ils étaient battre
c'était un problème qu'il préoccupé il
dessine et que s'ils n'étaient pas
possible de décrire très exactement un
visage et un autre visage on pouvait
trouver une règle de transformation très
simple qui permettait de passer de ce
visage à un visage b par une déformation
en elle-même facile à réaliser et bien
au fond le saut
réalisme c'est ça c'est en face d'objets
très compliqué de se dire nous
n'essayerons pas de décrire ces objets
dans les moindres détails parce que nous
n'y arriverions jamais une ville ne
serait pas suffisant pour décrire une
heure de la vie d'une société humaine de
50 personnes mais nous essaierons de
comprendre quelle est la différence
entre cette société et une autre société
et nous apercevons que si chacune de ces
sociétés prises apparaît très compliqué
en réalité la différence entre elles
la relation entre à lui peut-être plus
simple